comment ça va
aujourd'hui je voulais commencer cette
vidéo là en vous donnant trois termes
que je vais souvent utiliser donc
aujourd'hui on va les différencier
ensemble les mots sont et nous
inouïe
c'est le singulier ça veut dire une
personne je vais utiliser nous aussi
pour nommer deux personnes
ineuk et on a Inuit
inu T qui est le pluriel
de Inouk donc je vais l'utiliser de
cette façon là dans la langue Linux
Titou qui se traduit littéralement la
langue des inouïes je vais l'utiliser de
cette façon là pour représenter notre
culture comme par exemple je vais dire
je suis une nounouque de la culture
inouïe mais en inoxtitude on peut
utiliser ces mots-là pour décrire des
personnes des gens je sais pas si c'est
un peu plus clair je sais que ça peut
être maintenant pour certaines personnes
puis je sais aussi qu'on est mêlés avec
le mot inou i n
u parfois les zinous et noires vont se
faire appeler une mais non les inoises
les genoux sont à l'est du Québec puis
un peu laboratoire aussi mais après ça
les Inuits on est dans l'Arctique au
nord ça va être tout par rapport à ce
qui est des termes puis tantôt je
pensais à ça avant de filmer la vidéo
puis je trouvais ça important de vous
expliquer pourquoi c'est important pour
moi d'être ici souvent dans l'histoire
des autochtones on a peu mentionner les
inouïes comme par exemple je me rappelle
au secondaire on avait mentionné
peut-être une à deux fois le détroit de
Béring comme quoi les ennuis
mais c'est presque par rapport aux
Inuits déjà la base on parlait pas
beaucoup des autochtones des Premières
nations des métiers donc je suis
vraiment heureuse de pouvoir vous
rajouter un peu plus d'informations par
rapport à ça par rapport aux détroit de
Béring c'est intéressant parce que dans
ma culture j'ai appris en regardant dans
des livres en écoutant des documents
terre où on est informé par notre
famille par rapport à ça les amis disent
que nous avions des TO ME c'est des
géants qui vivaient avant nous sur le
territoire du nord et pourquoi il dit ça
c'est même scientifiquement impossible
de prouver le contraire c'est qu'on
aurait trouvé des roches qui seraient
utilisées pour les tentes pour maintenir
les tentes au sol mais disposer de façon
immense comme s'il y avait une grosse
tente qui avait désinstallé là que c'est
prolongé sur un grand parti de certains
territoires du Nord pour moi c'est
vraiment intéressant de vous partager ça
parce que on trans
à nos enfants petits-enfants puis même
aujourd'hui il y a des livres qui
parlent des géants ça fait une belle
histoire à partager je trouve ça encore
plus impressionnant ça fait partie de
nous c'est comme ça qu'on fonctionne
puis c'est un peu une façon aujourd'hui
de se réapproprie notre histoire à notre
façon comme quoi comment nous on l'a
entendu on essaie beaucoup de retourner
au sources donc merci d'avoir écouté je
vais dans la prochaine vidéo vous parler
d'un sujet un peu plus sensible qui est
sensible pour moi en tout cas parce que
ça parle d'une grosse partie de notre
histoire c'est la relocalisation des
inouïes donc on va en parler un peu plus
dans la prochaine vidéo merci beaucoup
d'accord mais